all right we're being super thorough
today we already looked at our
correspondent Luke Beasley's interviews
on the ground in Miami just to prove to
everyone that Luke wasn't hand selecting
or cherry-picking the craziest people
let's take just a little bit of a tour
through what we saw yesterday on
corporate media for example Fox News was
also out there doing interviews I guess
this is actually Fox Business and they
found a completely deranged guy this guy
is as deranged as anybody Luke found the
conspiracy theory this gentleman has is
that Hunter Biden started the war uh in
Ukraine
and that he actually started it five
years ago this is not us now this is not
Luke Beasley cherry picking this is Fox
businesses Griff Jenkins country the
most innocent man that's ever been in
the White House
Trump the
slash 40 seven he's coming back this is
the longest Witch Hunt going on eight
years now since he came down the
escalator you believe the guy's an
American hero do you believe there's a
two-tier system of justice do you
believe this is unfair obviously I don't
even know how anybody can ask that with
a straight face there's obviously a
two-tier justice system why is the
Clinton crime family running wild why is
Beijing Biden and the and the money
laundering operation that Hunter Biden
started out of uh Ukraine he started
that war on Ukraine five years ago when
he was working for barisma none of this
is true but I know I know most of you
know that last question If by uh Trump
were to get elected should he consider a
pardon for the Biden family absolutely
not they're a prime family you're either
an American or a Democrat these days
there's no way to be both all right
that's just as crazy as anybody that we
were able to find I mean just absolutely
no distinction we had Luke's interview
earlier in the show with the screaming
Cuban woman
um here is what this is a local station
LFA TV they found a crazy screaming
Cuban woman with many of the same ideas
we'll talk a little bit about the Cuban
American community and the context here
in a moment
doesn't go around the world you know
getting money like the clintons like
your mamas that all of the sudden
they're preaching communism This Woman's
also holding a beer for people who
aren't watching and are only listening
mother people live they have become rich
do your thing they care about Hispanics
do you think they care about Black
Americans no they don't they denigrade
us they want us to die crossing the
border
department when Daniel Ortega
the political opponents was the first
one to condemn that
he goes around the world preaching about
democracy about honesty with what moral
Authority is doing that when he is doing
exactly what is being done in Nicaragua
nothing reminds me more of the
Sandinista that the way that the
Democrats are operating in this country
there's no separation of powers they are
not treating Republicans the way that
they treat Democrats if we protest for
what they're doing to the children they
call us terrorists they think we are the
war terrorists and we are passionate
because I lost one nation okay so I
don't there's another minute of this I
won't subject you to that there is
actually a broader thing here I've
spoken to many of you before as an
argentinian-american myself about how
the vast majority of Hispanic Americans
folks from Central and South America the
vast majority of us are indeed on the
left there are some notable except
options primarily Cuban Americans and
Venezuelan Americans or Cubans in
Venezuelans who just came to the U.S
from those countries and it is a tough
situation because many of these folks
truly did flee horrifying regimes in
Cuba and in Venezuela there is no doubt
about that they are right to be angry at
and critical of the regimes that have
done so much damage in those countries
the problem is
after they flee those broken countries
they view anything as like if you're to
the left of John McCain or Chris
Christie essentially you are full-blown
communist Danger
and it is an unfortunate thing it seems
as though the Cuban Americans or Cubans
that we've heard from today uh certainly
are are suffering from that and it is
certainly a a sad situation
um okay Trump then went to a Cuban
restaurant uh he was Sullen and he had
his arms crossed in court then he went
straight to the Miami Cuban restaurant
Versailles which I may have been to
before although I don't I don't totally
remember it would have been about 12
years ago uh and in this restaurant it's
just a complete you know cult Fest they
start singing happy birthday to Trump
Trump's birthday is today yesterday was
the day before his birthday
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
happy birthday
37 felony counts let's sing the guy
happy birthday then in a completely
surreal kafka-esque moment supposed
Faith leaders prayed over Trump there's
a guy with a kippa or yamaka depending
on your preference he I believe is a
Cuban Jew and he you will hear him do a
little bit of Prayer in Hebrew and then
switch to Spanish as reminiscent and
nostalgic as this is for me hearing the
Hebrew mixed in with the Spanish this is
pretty horrifying stuff Faith leaders at
the Cuban restaurant praying over Trump
in Spanish there he's asking God to
protect this man with all and total
strength
give him strength in his hands give him
strength in his body he says
in the name of Jesus the the audio was a
little muddled there
[Applause]
okay so um that that happened and then
Trump announcing everybody having a
grand old time that he's buying food for
everybody are you ready are you ready
[Applause]
all right I would make sure to get a
credit card up front that is for damn
sure so a crazy day in Miami but even if
the average mag at magapatamian
magadonian is not abandoning Trump
increasingly Republican elected
officials are let's discuss that next
the weather is about to start warming up
and that often means sweating and
chafing and sticking sheath is the men's
underwear that once and for all puts an
end to all of that nonsense our sponsor
sheath underwear has designed unique
boxer briefs with an ergonomic
compartment built to keep everything
separate and dry and cool and
comfortable by allowing air to circulate
everywhere it needs to be no more
readjusting all day sheath offers a huge
variety of designs and patterns over
half a million pairs have already been
sold also check out their super
comfortable bamboo t-shirts sheath has
amazing customer service super fast
shipping along with over twenty thousand
five star reviews sheath is also
actively working with multiple
non-profits that deal with mental health
and homelessness which you support when
you get sheath underwear I've had a
great EXP experience with sheath
underwear I know you will too head on
over to sheathunderwear.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman for 20 off the link
is down below